parity-check now does anyone know other
word parity means parity does anyone
know what beyond the root word Park
means
par yeah it means equal so I am even
though I don't play it and I never will
because I'm too uncoordinated for the
main place we hear the word par is in
golf right we say people up on par right
which is something to do with equality
and you're up to a certain standard okay
or your 3 under par or whatever it is
okay so parody is really just a fancy
word for equality or if you like
equivalents equivalents as you'll see is
probably a better term to go for it okay
so how does this work remember on a
network right we send data um and we
send it in little discrete chunks
remember what they were call starts an
IP packets correct
now packets can vary in size okay but
all of the most common packet sizes is
one byte okay and one byte as you know
is short for eight bits okay so that's
about this up so here's a byte
okay and it's got eight little spots and
they're bit so I can put a 0 or a 1 in
any of these ok
so for instance I might want to send you
know 1 1 0 0 1 will learn the Tetra and
I send it off that's my packet ok but
when it's Simplot say this is 1 1 0 0 1
1 1
ok as it gets sent along as an
electrical signal when it arrives it
might look different
ok so some electromagnetic field
interferes with my cabling ok or there's
some kind of signal loss so perhaps what
gets received I do that right yeah
keycap okay
has some alterations in it now because
it's just zeros or ones ok
suppose this one here it gets it's a bit
weak up ok now if it's just a little bit
weaker and the receiving computer my
guess I'd still a 1 it's still close
enough
ok but this 0 here for instance ok
suppose some interference came in and it
was so strong that this part of the
signal will closer to a 1 than it did to
a 0 ok so what might be received is this
and the question for you is how might we
tell that you know this is what arrives
at you
ok and like what's the difference
between these things what number is this
this is 1 2 4 8 16 32 100 and so I see
it's down to 64 64 128 so this number is
actually 5 1377 205 205 ok where is this
the difference was a 32 ok so this is
actually gonna be 237 so how do you know
that I meant to send this and not that
like how can you tell right now in real
life how do we do this you say something
and I miss here you I hear this what
would I do
or what would you do if you think you
misheard me what would you do you'd say
you'd say we actually we have code for
this we have a arm we have a protocol we
have an agreed-upon set of rules right
that would tell me ok you say something
like say huh I just think about that ok
seriously like what in that tells me
communicates to me oh I did not I'm not
entirely sure that that was what you
meant to send would you please repeat
your signal so that I can verify the
result what's in there it doesn't mean
anything it's just that we've agreed
upon that like we've learnt through
picking out language it's like oh that
means you didn't get it okay I'll say it
again right now thing is me computers
what's that what's the huh
and how would you know like for instance
suppose I'm wearing conversation and you
ask me you know how old are you right
and I say what you hear me say is oh I'm
I'm I'm 205 okay now you would say
rightly huh right now why why would you
say that if you like I said it very
clearly why wouldn't you think I'm 205
because it's a nonsensical result right
and you have intuition you're clever
firstly right and see like that can't be
there for huh okay but but a computer
right there's no that is that intuition
there's no common sense they're just
numbers
okay so what's it going to do here's
what they have devised as a solution
okay
our packets are still the same size
they're still in work that I get it
right 1 2 3 4 5 ok still in lots of 8
what you do is you take the first 7 and
that's the part that you use for your
message or for your signal that's what
you're actually going to send what they
stick on the end is something called a
parity bit it's called a bit because
there's just one of them and it's called
parity because it's what we'll use to
check ok
so let's take a different number let's
take my real age this time which is 27
ok so you've got these seven bits okay
to communicate that number okay so 27
what 27 I can fit what's the biggest
power to I can feel 60 into that and
then that'll leave me with
that'll leave me with love em so I can
fit H into that sixteen and now they
agree with three so two and one
okay so what numbers am I going to write
I need to get a 1 1 2 8 and 16 okay now
remember this guy on the end what we
used to say this is the first bit okay
we ignore him we don't have him as an
option anymore
okay so this is my 1 okay so there's one
here's my 2 this would be 4 but I don't
want any fours right so that's a 0
here's my 8 here's my 16 and then I'm
not that old so I just leave those on ok
all right now what does the parity bit
do there are two kinds of parity I'll
explain them in a second but for now
what you would do is you'd say look I
want you count these are ones okay
and I say I want an even number of ones
in my whole packet okay now you have a
look at how many ones there are right
now there are four okay so what should I
put on the end to make this even I'll
put a zero because if I put a 1 there be
five ones right and it would be odd okay
so in another color baby I'm going to
put zero there okay that ensures that
there's an even number of ones along
here okay now let's consider what would
happen if there was interference
okay so you can see what's happened
right from what I wanted to send or what
I did send suppose this is what is
received okay what's the difference just
one bit has changed okay it is this bit
here it's not it's no longer correct
okay now what what age would this be
this would be missing the two okay so
this would be 25 now even you with all
your intuition would say well that's
still within acceptable balance right
that could be legit right so how do we
know that this is actually wrong well
you have a look and you think well okay
how many ones are there okay and we've
agreed upon the fact that it always has
to be or using this method of checking
it always has to be an even number of
ones and you're looking to see well
there's three ones so this clearly must
be wrong okay whatever was sent this
couldn't have been in okay and so what
you would say is huh well actually the
computer would say that but it would
request for you to resend the data or me
to resend the data okay so this is what
we call even parity because I always
wanted an even number of ones okay you
can imagine this oh there's another
version of this which is odd parity
right so this is even let's come back to
what I wanted to say
okay what I wanted to send was one one
zero one zero zero okay
now suppose we will end up on parent
just you and me we just agreed okay that
we always want to have an odd number of
ones in each packet okay when I have a
look at the parity bit and I'm about to
send to you what should I put in there a
one right
I'll put it another color because now
there's an odd number of ones okay and
when it arrives at you sweat you'll know
that it's right so this is on okay now
because I'm told me um this is good
it'll catch out a lot of the errors that
are going to come through but there are
real problems with this method of
checking right can anyone suggest one
yeah pocket is the parent you get all
the through ah well ok let's try that
shall we ah suppose this is let's now go
on an odd parity okay suppose on this
odd this parity bit along the end does
get altered okay so instead of 0 0 1 1 0
1 1 1
instead the parameter is alternate I get
0 ok are you going to know that this is
wrong you will right you will know that
it's wrong because there's still an even
number of our ones and we were looking
we said I'm always going to send you old
ones every single time they should be
always so you will know that there were
some problems ok but there is another
issue yeah okay so suppose like Pike
suggested the parity bit was altered but
also the one I was talking about before
is 2 also gets altered ok so again I'm
25 ok but this is an odd number of ones
it's still or check out ok so you be
like yeah sure why not
it checks out the rules right it makes
sense there's an odd number of ones too
should be ok right
so the parity check how does it work
number one it has this bit on the end
which we call parity bit and it's not
actually sending a message it's just
telling you whether the message is ripe
or not ok but it's got some big problems
with it
it's got some glaring holes lots of
errors will creep through okay now